hey guys dog walker here guess what I
just saw the Angry Video Game Nerd movie
they were kind enough to get me tickets
to go see it here in Chicago at the
premiere I introduced it a little bit
they allow me to do that - very cool
home and movie started and I'm here to
tell you what my thoughts are it's
pretty obvious I'm not going to dislike
it because that would be pretty douchey
and that not because like I did if I
didn't like I didn't like it but I
wouldn't go do it for you I got it
I would either apply or find a way to
talk about it where I didn't have to
really talk about my real thoughts but
uh no this was um you know this is a
this is important but we really can't
we're talking about because it's a film
it you know it was done through
Kickstarter and in my opinion this is
kind of the ultimate fan movie we see
all these fan films but here is a film
that's financed by fans made by a fan
made for the fans and it's not just one
subject it's it would be so easy for
this film to just be video game nerd
jokes you know nothing else and nothing
but callbacks to his other jokes or him
just wearing but with big explosions
going on or something um but no this is
a very cleverly well done movie and when
I first I was given the script before
before they even started shooting uh
because we did this we did auditions in
Chicago for it and I read the script and
I looked through it and I loved the
story but I was saying to myself how the
hell is he gonna do this like I saw the
budget I got for it I'm like even with
that budget I don't know how this is
gonna work I don't know how any of this
is gonna fly and so it sounds weird but
leading up to this movie I was really
concerned I was like really really
concerned because it's like I hope this
is good cause so many people thrown
money into it and James is so talented
but I just
I'm thinking about this grant I was just
like man I hope this pays off and it
really really does it's and I bring that
up because anytime somebody says you
know why that actor do this movie or why
this director pick that script or
somebody didn't they couldn't they tell
it was a bad script when you get someone
that really knows what they're doing and
has this very clear vision they can take
pretty much the exact same words and
turn to something really clever and you
got just let them experiment you gotta
let them play with it and some people
can't some people can't turn you know at
nothing into something or something
nothing whatever um they but but James
really did and he did something that you
know it helped if you know the nerd but
you don't have to uh it's pretty much
just a celebration of everything very
traditionally geeky it's kind of the
celebration of sci-fi as a celebration
of monster movies a celebration of comic
book celebration of zombie films uh
there's even a joke at Ninja Turtles 3
in this but it's even if you didn't know
what did you throw three was you would
still laugh at the joke because the
effects in this are very how do I put
there very cleverly corny but you hear
then you think oh why gave all that
money it didn't even go into making the
effects know what's so clever is that
it's this perfect jealous perfect mix of
live-action and CG but in all the right
places and it's impressive where it
needs to look impressive it's cheesy
where it needs to look cheesy because
it's also it's a monster film and with
all these things he's trying to hit with
all these sort of very classic genres
you know of monster films of superhero
films and sci-fi films uh they all have
these kind of distinct styles and he's
combining them all into one and it's
surprisingly really really gels and it's
funny and and it's clever and the use of
the effects there's a lot practical
effects that
you know watching it are fake it's
illusion but at the same time when you
see when you see this giant monster
running through Vegas and he's hitting
this casino he's playing his arm through
a casino you know it's a model and you
know it's a guy in a suit but you also
know it's there it's really
there and it it really wasn't always saw
this film I realize how much we really
do rely way too goddamn much on CGI
because CGI we know is not there it
looks good it almost looks like it's
there like you took a still picture
maybe it could for you that's kind of a
big maybe but we've had it gloss over
everything and so now we're looking at
nothing we're looking at these very
nice-looking cartoon there's not that
against animation you know I love
animation but it's it's two filters now
it's where with models it's one filter
cuz it's really there it's just not to
scale it's not the actual size it's not
the actual place it's not the casino
being destroyed but when okay
Godzilla like and don't get me wrong the
final fight in the new Godzilla movie
was cool but when he's revving up his
tail and blow on the fire and the thing
I don't know that's there it it looks
cool but it's nothing's there and it's
all a computer and when people are
running away from it you know it's again
I I know they're just running away from
a computer with this when something hits
a building you know what's really
hitting it so that when these five
pieces fly out they're gonna fly out in
a way that's not calculated that's not
painted over that was really there and
it's going to have an impact that's
different than a person typing it in so
it's so strange because watch these
effects and be like what's obviously a
guy in a suit but at least it's really a
guy in the suit at least it's a really a
guy who's there and so when the impact
happens you feel the impact because the
impact is really
there and I really didn't know how I
don't want to say spoil because we're
not spoiled by computer graphics I'm
eight in animation like Pixar DreamWorks
II and I did we we are you know and and
they're doing great but in the the use
of films I watch Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles I've watched for things that are
not there run around and I just shrug
and say they're not there i why am i
watching is there clearly not there uh
but for this even though I know they're
not it's not a real monster it's not
real building I know they actually built
these things and I felt that hid and
there's so many scenes like that where
these little models will fall and they
look incredibly fake but you really feel
them falling there's this gut reaction
in you that feels the impact so it was
very very clever to do that and it
really make me it made me realize the
effort and kind of what we were missing
with like just even the old classic
monster movies are just a lot of effects
there's there's got to be a middle
ground there's got to be in there lor
the rings in there somewhere um cuz yeah
we're missing something
uh but I okay so I really went off in
the effects there um but again a lava
Mars are meant to look fake like my
favorite is there's this reuse shot of
like you know whenever the monster
destroyed say he'll get like three or
four people like in from a green screen
doing this and it's it's clearly meant
to look fake but here's why it works
there's this and why I did know was
going to work but it really paid off is
there's this kinetic energy throughout
the whole thing that the only thing I
can think of I'm shows our examples but
the first thing comes my mind is
probably the lego movie where the lego
movie is also fake their Legos you know
and I think they're mostly CG but you
know it's you also kind of enjoy like
when they build something it's you don't
see them actually take apart every
single thing put it over here they'll
build it like a stop-motion lego video
it's kind of like that it's welcoming
the you know
or the comedy and the cheesiness of it
but it's also not it's not being it's
not cheating if there's no cheating in
this movie everything is done as much
practically as possible that would get a
laugh and then something else like
somebody's telling a story about the
origin of this monster that's going to
be shown in these sort of CG puppets
going on that even actually even then
they can look like drawings but you kind
of know okay that would make sense for
this uh and there's a scene where
somebody has like an epiphany and the
UCM wake up and realize something and it
shoots through the universe that has to
be CG it's funnier if it's done through
CG in that way so I think that's what I
really I think it's why I respect with
the effects is that it knew it wasn't
just an just some live action some
computer-generated whatever it kind of
knew what was going to get the biggest
laugh with what effect and again a lotta
came from the kinetic energy and good
editing in this - again there's a lot of
lines where if they just sort of read
the way they read it it get an okay
laughs whatever but it was really good
at cutting away to another person's
reaction and expression - to counteract
a you know to take a line those may be
okay but then when you have the
expression on top of it it'll be really
funny and well that's it good casting in
this - um these are actors that are
obviously allowed to improvise a little
bit and I think they took a lot of
scenes that were probably okay and made
them even better and it just made them
much more alive and the whole film I
when when James came back to the from
this to shoot the Kami or fortable
Leafly uh he was just like shaking he
was just like yeah okay hi so I did that
II you know and it's I I get it I mean
it's like that I've never done anything
quite that big but it's like even for
the stuff I've done it's pretty intense
I can't imagine the stuff he went
through and to still keep that energy
going throughout the whole thing even
though it
probably driving you bonkers I mean this
is why I say every film even the bad
ones are something of a little miracle
really you know cuz they're just so
difficult to put together and to put
together and keep good because there's
so many people that wanna keep putting
the thumb prints on there uh and in this
one it it really all just came down to
James it came down to him trying to keep
this and trying to get his vision alive
and what he wanted to see and keep it
funny and take out things but in things
whatever just what he thought worked and
it really works and you just kind of
feel like you saw some guys you know
just his really fun fan film that he
worked really hard on and you say that
was really good and I and I and it's
really enjoyable it's not something
where it's like oh well I like it
because he's a friend or whatever it's
actually really enjoyable and he very
cleverly worked in uh what limitations
he would have because even though he had
an unbelievable budget for this there's
still limitations um you know if it
watches be logs and all the stuff about
the making of Emmy you'll clearly see it
even people with these massive budgets I
mean that they're all gonna have
limitations at some point but he was so
good at working them in and once a while
there's something like maybe it's not
quite focused or something like that but
I mean it's they're very very minor and
it just I don't know if it's through the
editing through the performers and
through just a good story it's a good
idea uh it was always a really really
good story and a good idea and I think
just all of that coming together in just
this really fun spirit the spirit of
let's just put on a movie have fun this
is just a really fun silly big movie it
feels big you don't I can't see anyone
leaving this thing like really that's as
what we were waiting for I think so many
people are going to walk in and get the
movie they want to see and it's funny it
has practical effects it has CG effects
it has all sorts of different kinds of
comedy it's not all gross out acting
it's you know that there's a lot of puns
there's a lot of social commentary
actually there's great commentary on
just what he does and like his fan base
and what it means to be a part of this
fan base but it never it never takes it
too seriously it never quite goes into
like he is the savior or anything like
that it's very much uh it's very much
this very clever kind of satire and it's
it just works out really well and I
think it's because it just has this very
upbeat energy and it knows very much
what it wants to include in there what
it wants to samurai a while wants to
satirize and it just throws everything
at you and it's it's just fun it's a
great fun big movie uh and it's uh it's
kind of silly talking about because I
know that whoever has tickets already
has and they're like all sold out and
whoever wants the DVD is going to buy
the DVD but yeah just my thoughts
initially it's I think it's it's a good
movie we're talking about because like I
said I do kind of see it as the ultimate
fan film it just it feels complete for
what it was supposed to be and yeah I
think anyone who's going to go see this
film you're gonna have a great time even
if you don't know who the nerd is he
does a pretty good job introducing you
to it and you know watching it in some
respects it's gonna be low budget in our
respect it's gonna be very big budget
and it it balances it out in such a
funny way and it's it's a very well-done
film it really is and it pays off for
all the people are like oh when's it
coming when it's it it's a good payoff
and I think you guys are really gonna
have a lot of fun with it so that's
about it and hopefully if you don't have
tickets go get them and if not go buy
the DVD you definitely won't you won't
regret it so that's about it I'll talk
to you later
take care